you know what's really funny I saw a
post on I think ESPN or SportsCenter or
whatever and it was like a NBA game like
dudes and they like no one could make a
shot in like the longest time and it was
like a funny clip and the caption was
like what is going on here and then all
these women were in the comments going
see it's not just WNBA you guys do it
too and all these guys are like yo the
reason it's posted is because it's rare
[Music]
yeah
there's a high school basketball coach
that recently has been fired after
posing as a 13 year old in a JV basket
like why do people do that what's the
win so he did windmill dunk she she
oh really I heard about a guy that did
this it's a sheet this is a sheet this
is you heard about you heard about this
there was a guy who was like 25 years
old and he like held himself back in
high school and he was like falling out
dude so this is uh some CCTV footage I
guess that was like less than Sparks
yeah wait how old is she this one with
the arrow right here with the coach
I will uh give you some more information
I wanted to play with high school kids
22 year old high school basketball coach
is out of a job now after trying to pass
as a 13 year old player in a JV game
earlier this month 13 years old uh her
name is arlisha Boykins an assistant
doing Skyhook in the [__] thumbnail
there off the glass an assistant for
this Churchland High School truckers in
Virginia impersonated one of her players
who was away from the team for a club
basketball tournament probably the best
player oh she impersonated her own
player okay that makes sense that's
smart well it's still not right well I
mean at least it's a clear uh motive
yeah yeah how old are these people
oh JV dude 22 poses 13 was this a CW
Show like that doesn't work it's a UK
show everyone's gonna know so instead of
athletes are different though yeah but
even when like like say like LeBron's
kid right when he was 13
in like the whatever League that he
plays in you're like he looks like a man
in a bot like like he looks like a man
but his face looks like a small child
she for sure probably looks like a girl
it's like a Dominican baseball player
I'm 13. also oh so it's like really fast
yeah and then just shoot like this
and just cover your face so instead of
playing with one less Hooper Boykins
apparently took matters into her own
hands and suited up as the student
athlete and uh footage obviously shows
her just wrecking everybody that's Ty
this is like good this is like a in the
air of Joanna man this would be a movie
yeah yeah
did she have to like ball out though
like she couldn't like yeah did she have
to stand down I just missed a couple oh
man air ball the funny thing too is that
everybody knows she's the coach
yeah who's coaching them what is one of
the Scruples of this whole school that
they're in on this dude as usual
ain't nobody's watching women's
basketball there's like three people
maybe that's why she did it dance bro
nobody who knows except for the other
team that's why she did it she's like it
doesn't matter no one gives a [__] no
one's here someone needs a standing yeah
this is this is the reference that Steve
wrote about bro even their [__]
parents aren't there there's more team
members watching your own parents aren't
going aren't showing up is this a
syndicated [__]
oh my gosh give me a break already yeah
maybe she was just like it's
inconsequential this is on TV but then
now she lost her job even the ref's not
looking he's turning the other way uh
it's actually the JV coach and the
varsity head coach are all fired the JV
coach allowed it to happen I mean that's
just such a weird thing for everybody to
be complicit in and it's a JV game no no
player was like I'm not gonna play if
you're pulling that ridiculous even the
teammates well they could have been
hyped about it but [__] yeah coaches in
yeah they probably were I would have
been hyped that's true and and plus like
if the coach is saying it they're
probably these kids are like oh yeah
like I guess we're allowed to it's not
the kid's fault it's [__] their fault
and if the coach is gonna ball out and
you just get to kind of chill and watch
your coach he's throwing her alley oops
that's what that's what kind of says a
lot about the mental state or that whole
school probably but this is something
they would do and everyone just go yeah
that's funny it would have been better
if she was like if she was breaking
everyone's ankles and [__] and then just
like pointing at him like stepping over
him like Iverson dribbling through their
legs yeah dude
the coach was a dude wearing like a wig
no that's why I draw the line now is
that guy the professor on YouTube to
[__] dribble all over these people I
love it and keep the Spider-Man costume
on too
because you're taking everyone for
idiots already you might as well dude
now I know if I see a guy with a
Spider-Man costume with a basketball
I'll be like ah you know I need help
yeah yeah not tricking me senior citizen
comes up to court you know they're gonna
be the best that's Kyrie Irving I know
that's Kyrie Irving a guy with a with a
cane and he's got he's got sunglasses on
he's like oh I'm so blind
I don't know if I'm gonna fall for this
one
can I shoot some moves with you guys
everyone's like yeah right old blind man
he could never make it on these courts
and ignore it completely ignore the
cameras all around too you know the best
this is the part where you keep ripping
I do I don't want to talk about this
anymore
[Music]
[Laughter]
JV women's basketball we just rang that
rag up for [__] five minutes yeah
yeah you know what's funny though so
mark keppel this the high school team
right here
we actually went to a women's uh uh the
the JV I mean actually dude what was it
were you saying like that
we actually won because they were
crushing it way better than the guys and
then the game was actually were they
playing against girls
nope not just kidding
what was exciting about it they were
making shots Non-Stop
that's that's fun that's always fun
that's actually cool I'd love to see
that yeah see a woman making shots yeah
over and over
lots of free throws usually when I watch
WNBA it's a bunch of air balls
is it how I'm pretty sitting down and
actually watching a WNBA game I have to
be go after walking by actually have you
guys ever watched the full WNBA game I
have yeah yeah because I because our
school used to sing national anthem at
WNBA games for the uh Sparks or whatever
the hell they were oh or whatever the
hell they were to be honest though I
don't think any of us have time to watch
a full NBA game I haven't been watching
my choice yeah like when's the last time
you sat down and actually watched I did
watch the Lakers Celtics game
I heard that was a good game that was
[__] up dude the no call you know
what's really funny I saw a post on I
think ESPN or Sports Center or whatever
and it was like a NBA game like dudes
and they like no one could make a shot
in like the longest time and it was like
a funny clip and the caption was like
what is going on here and then all these
women were in the comments going see
it's not just WNBA you guys do it too
and all these guys are like yo the
reason it's posted is because it's rare
and that's why it's funny I think I saw
that clip I think that was a college
basketball game oh it was a college game
oh okay yeah so we watched an entire
Lakers game last year
so we do we do watch those the last year
it was just citing the truth they get
one have you guys played like in an
organized sports like team like in high
school I was in JV Basketball because
you're tall right that's what typically
happens yeah I played an adult league
like after what sport basketball oh yeah
I'm just a little group of friends I
played an intramural but I sucked what's
that we won
it's where you make teams within the
school and the school plays itself oh
yeah whoever's the best those are fun
though
I played basketball for a month until I
got kicked out of school my team sucked
so bad that we lost every single game
that year I'm not lying we lost every
single game you were the practice you
got swept that everyone was like all
right we're gonna start the season with
these guys yeah well and my my teacher
was the he was like the coach or
whatever did he ever suit up with you
guys no but he came he like was excited
because I guess he came from another
program and he's like I'll coach JV
Basketball here and then they fired him
the next year because we sucked that
much ass dude there's nothing worse than
getting destroyed in a basketball game
it sucks like the like the way another
team will like blow you out it's like
the worst feeling ever because
especially when they're hot and they're
just making every single [__] Basket
in your face and they're all getting
hyped their teammates are going crazy
and then you guys can't even [__]
make a basket because it's a repetitive
accident yeah bro it's just like you
just get pounded it's not like a clean
knockout in the first round it's like
someone owned your ass for five rounds
and you gotta do three more quarters of
it you're like you know what I imagine
they get demoralized and start arguing
within the team and [__] I [__] I
said it too yeah yeah you just get mad
at everybody really sucks is when your
school is playing an infamously good
school and your own students go to the
game to see the infamously good school
kick your ass oh yeah our high school
was likely really [__] good at
basketball like they would win the CIF
Championship every year so it was like
going to watch the boys basketball like
team was like were the girls good too
they were pretty good but like not many
people it was like a spectacle though
right like yeah it was like a whole
thing Stadium's packed out well because
everybody was rallying behind the team
but like when they lost it'd be like oh
my God they lost that's like Mark kepple
with badminton they were crushing it no
I know we had like Olympic athletes we
had two Olympians I think that's in high
school our football team was whack
though dude they look like it's funny
because how different it is when you're
in an all Asian school versus like my my
original high school gridina high our
football team was like adult size
because it was just Polynesians and
black yeah so like those games were so
exciting I had a ninth grade friend that
was in the the varsity team it was it
was exciting to watch
but uh when he came to keppel it was
like all the opposite Sports what are
you preparing I'm trying to find the
wreck our record our actual middle
school right now I'm like this guy's
preparing a closer of some sort so yeah
high school football team record I think
it was 10 wins in 11 years yeah holy
[__] so not even one win a year 10 wins
and 11. at that point you gotta [__]
tear down the football field they keep
it going dude 11 years yeah because it's
a whole team of five foot Asian kids
that are that are like about a buck a
hundred pounds that's hard and it's a
security guard that's the head coach
yeah like the sports Department sucked
ass it wasn't an actual like you're not
gonna get recruits you're not gonna get
good kids that want to play football no
but all the all the sports like dude we
had a golf team we had a badmin team all
the Asian sports though we killed it
yeah
I didn't like it decathlon that's the
Asian sport yeah dude Geography Bee
killing it I remember having to do a
spelling bee and losing to bookkeeper
how do you get the KK I got I got Ninth
Place for the district because I missed
undulate
you just don't forget the one you missed
yeah never really never forget it
bookkeep that's that's [__] up they
have 2ks in there I was like are you
kidding me right now that's [__]
because yeah b-o-ook they just snap any
clipboards I was honestly
pissed and they know when they give you
that word they're like he's gonna miss
the king Steve's like can you use it in
a sentence yeah it doesn't help at all I
don't know how kids get more spelling
from that he's like it's bookkeeper you
[__]
aren't they just buying time like what
are they gonna find out about it from
using in the sentence what does that do
yeah it's a little hack I think when
they they do that the funny thing is
like I was like I was so mad because I'm
like I've never [__] heard that word
it's not real undulated what the hell is
that that week there was like a American
gliders ripoff TV show I think it was
called wmac Masters or something oh and
then they were like event number one the
undulating steel and I went God damn it
yeah I was like no way it's real
this sounds like underwear to me
thankfully bookkeepers are going extinct
[Music]
foreign